غاره اسرائيليه على غزه تقتل 12 شخصا
بينهم ثلاثه من القياديين العسكريين في
حركه الجهه
وتزامنا مع احتفالات يوم النصر انظمه
الدفاع الجوي الاوكرانيه تتصدى لهجمات
الروسي على العاصمه ومعظم مدن البلاد
مع تصاعد وتيره الاشتباكات البرهان يحذر
من انتقال الصراع من الدعم السريع او مع
الدعم السريع الى ولايه اخرى في السودان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم يلا يلا
من العربيه اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي عن مقتل
قائد منطقه شمال قطاع غزه في حركه الجهاد
وقياديهم بارز في الحركه وامين سر المجلس
العسكري فيها في عمليه مشتركه تمت
بالتنسيق بين الجيش والمخابرات
الاسرائيليه واستهدفت مواقع لحركه الجهاد
ومنازل لقادته في القطاع الجيش الاسرائيلي
افاد بمقتل القيادي في سرايا القدس وقائد
لواء غزه خليل البهتيني في العمليه
وبالمقتل القيادي في حركه الجهاد طارق عز
الدين في القصف الاسرائيلي كما ادى القصف
الى مقتل جهاد غانم القيادي في الحركه
وزوجته وزاره الصحه في القطاع فادت بسقوط
نحو 12 قتيلا وعشرين جريحا فيما اعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي مواصله ضرباته على غزه
كما اعلن اغلاق طرق ومواقع وطالب
بالانتقال الى طرقات بديله في مناطق غلاف
غزه
هذا واكد الاعلام الاسرائيلي ان رئيس
الوزراء سيعقد اجتماعا اليوم للحكومه
الامنيه المصغره المكتب والحكومي في غزه
اعلن بدوره تعليق الدراسه والاعمال
الرسميه كما اكدت حركه الجهاد من جانبها
مقتل قياديها وقالت انها لن تغادر مواقعها
وانها سترد من حيث انتهت اخر مواجهه مع
اسرائيل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وهذه صور من مدينه غزه مع اطلاله الصباح
الاولى بعد ليله عاصفه بالغارات
الاسرائيليه والتي ادت كما اشرنا الى مقتل
12 شخصا بينهم ثلاثه من القيادات العسكريه
في الجهاد بالاضافه الى خمسه مدنيين قتلوا
جراء القصف الاسرائيلي وفي هذا القصف ايضا
اصيب عشرون جرحا
في قطاع غزه
وكما تتابعون في هذه اللقطات كانت انبات
تتحدث عن ان الغارات الاسرائيليه
تواصلت بعد ذلك في تحليق للطائرات
الاسرائيليه فوق قطاع غزه بعد استخدام في
القياديين في حركه الجهاد الاسلامي فجرا
هذا اليوم وليله البارحه مما اتى الى مقتل
الاثني عشر شخصا بينهم ثلاثه من القيادات
التي اعترفت حركه الجهاد بمقتلهم خلال
الغار الاسرائيليه وكما نشير بان هناك
مدنيين قد سقطوا جراء الغارات الاسرائيليه
التي تحدث الجيش الاسرائيلي لمخابرات
الاسرائيليه بانها
مركزه على اهداف لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
مواقع عسكريه
مخازن ذخيره انفاق كما يقول الجانب
الاسرائيلي وكما اشرنا حركه الجهاز
الاسلامي
توعدت بالرد من حيث انتهت المواجهات
الاخيره في تصعيد ورد فعل من الحركه على
الغارات الاسرائيليه
نتابع تطورات من غزه مع الصحفي محمد عوض
اهلا بك محمد ما تفاصيل الغاره
الاسرائيليه وهل انتهى تحليق الطيران
الاسرائيلي فوق القطع
يعني
جمله كبيره من الغارات ليس غاره واحده فقط
نتحدث عن اربعين طائره عسكريه شاركت في
هذا التصعيد المفاجئ حسب ما قال الناطق
اسم الجيش الاسرائيلي قبل قليل في تصريح
صحفي بان 40 40 طائرا ما بين مروحيه
واستطلاع وحربيه شاركت في اختيار قاده
الجهاد الاسلامي الثلاثه الذين تم
استهدافهم داخل شقق السكنيه في مدينه غزه
وفي شرق مدينه غزه كذلك الامر جنوب قطاع
غزه نبدا
بالتفاصيل ما حدث في تمام الساعه الثانيه
فجرا بتوقيت غزه
سمعه عدويه عده انفجارات في مدينه غزه
وشرقها وجنوب لطائر غزه اتضح ان طائرات
اسرائيليه قد شنت غارات متزامنه في وقت
واحد وهذا يعني ان العمليه مدبره باحكام
وبشكل دقيق جدا حيث اغارت الطائرات
الاسرائيليه على المباني الثلاثه بعدد
كبير من الصواريخ كنا ننقل عبر العربيه
والحدث من مكان الاستهدافات حيث شاهدنا
حجم الدمار الكبير الذي لحقه بمنازل
المواطنين ولحق بالمناطق
على هذه النقطه محمد الاستهدافات تمت
لاولئك القياديين داخل منازلهن مع
عائلاتهم في مباني ليست مخصصه فقط لحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي وانما مباني يسكنها
اولا الشقه الاولى التي تقع في حي الرمال
ومحمد كما تعلم الجميع يعلم بان حي الرمال
هو منطقه
يعني منطقه تجاريه وسكنيه
ويسكن بداخل هذه المنطقه مواطنين ويوجد
محلات تجاريه معروفه وضخمه وشارع يصل لشرق
غزه بغربه
وكانت العمليه العسكريه على هذا المبنى
الذي يقع وسط حي الرمال بشكل مفاجئ الامر
الذي ادى الى احداث اضرار كبيره جدا في
العماره السكنيه التي استلفت من كل
الاتجاهات وهذه السياسه العسكريه التي
تتخذها اسرائيل للاغتيال حيث كانت في مرض
صادقه قد اغتسير الجابري قبل 19 وقبل عامي
اخترت ابو العطاء بنفس هو نفس التوقيت
اليوم اسرائيل تعيد الاغتيال ثلاثه من
ابرز القاده العسكريين الذين يتبعون
للجهاد الاسلامي وكما نوهنا في رسائل
سابقه بان هؤلاء القاده كان يصعب يعني
ظهورهم على الاعلام ويتنقلون بحذر شديد
وان اسرائيل دائما تحملهم المسؤوليه عن
اطلاق صواريخ من قطاع غزه اتجاه البلدات
الاسرائيليه واليوم حينما سالت الثلاثه
القاده الميدانيين التابعين للجهاد
الاسلامي قالت اسرائيل بان هؤلاء الثلاثهم
مسؤولين عن الاطلاق الصواريخ من قطاع غزه
من جانب ومن جانب اخر تفعيل خلايا داخل
الضفه الغربيه تحديدا وجهه الاتهام الى
القائد في الجهاد الاسلامي طالق عز الدين
وهو الذي اصوله تعود الى مخيم جنين الذي
ابعد عنه قصرا بعد اعتقاله وابرام صفقه
تبادل بين الفصول الفلسطينيه
لكن هنا عن اثني عشر قتيلا ثلاثه من قياده
او قياديه جهاد الاسلامي ماذا عن بقيه
القتل جراء الغاره الاسرائيليه هل هناك من
تفاصيل اخرين
الاسعاف محمد لحظه القصف ولحظه الاغتيال
تفاجئنا بعنا الاشلاء ممزقه في كل مكان
اطفال قد لقوا حقهم وهناك اصابات
متناثره في كل مكان من بين الضحايا اطفال
كانوا على الارض وقد تحشمت رؤوسهم وكان
ايضا هناك طبيب يعمل في مركز طبي لرعايه
المرضى ايضا لقى حطه بجوار زوجته وافراد
عائلته كان يسكنون بجانب الشقه التي تم
استهدافها الاكتضاض السكاني الكبير الذي
يقع في تلك المناطق الثلاثه مثلا حي الشعب
الى الشرق من غزه كان له نصيب الاسد من
القصد حيث استهدفت اسرائيل
الطائر وعسكري في الجهاد الاسلامي في
منطقه الشعب ويعرف هذا هذا الحي او حي
الشعب حي يعني السكني ويعتبر حي الشجاعيه
هو الحي الاكثر تكدسا بالسكان على مستوى
قطاع غزه وانت تعلم الجميع يكون في ثبات
عميق من النوم نتيجه ان ساعه متاخره من
الليل وبشكل يعني غير موحد له للاختيار
خاصه ان الاغتيال جاء بعد نجاح مصر والامم
المتحده بعوده الهدوء الى قطاع غزه
الاسبوع الماضي بعد وفاه خضر عدنان داخل
السجون الاسرائيليه لكن روما الوساطه
المصريه ورغم الوساطه الدوليه التي
اوقفت التصعيد في قطاع غزه الا ان الاعلام
الاسرائيلي لوحه اليوم ان المستوى
الاستخبارات
يقول يوصي باغتيال وعمليه استباقيه في
قطاع غزه اليوم وبعد 10 ساعات تقريبا من
هذه التصاريح التي انتشرت عبر العلامه
الاسرائيلي تقوم 40 طائره اسرائيليه بقصف
هذه الاحياء المدنيه هذه كانت الجزء الاول
من العمليه العسكريه التي بدات بالفعل على
ارتفاع غزه وكنا في المجمع دار الشفاء
الطبي نشاهد حجم الاصابات التي ياتي بها
جمله
لمواقع تابعه لحركه الجهاد حركه
هذا ما كنت ساتحدث به ثم عادت الطائره
وكنا في المجمع دار الشفاء الطبي نشاهد
حجم الاصابات التي ياتي بها جمله معرفه
تابعه لحركه الجهاد حركه
الطائرات بعد نصف ساعه من هذه الاغتيال
بقصف مواقع كبيره للجهاز الاسلامي في جنوب
قطاع غزه تحديدا
محاربه الجهاد الاسلامي توعدت بالرد كيف
سيكون الرد من الحركه كما توعد
الامور والاوضاع خاصه بعد اغتيال ابرز
ثلاثه قاده في الجهاد الاسلامي في قطاع
غزه لكن الشكل الرد وحجم الرد هذا كله
مرهون بالتوقيت الذي سيمر على قطاع غزه
خلال الساعات القادمه لان اليوم هناك غرفه
غرفه عمليات مشتركه بين الفصل 1600
والجميع ينتظر لتشييع جثمين الضحايا دور
هذا اليوم في رفح وفي غزه وفي شرق غزه
الانظار تتجه الى قطاع غزه والجميع ينظر
ما ستقول اليها الامور بعد تشجيع جثمين
هؤلاء الضحايا لانه في تفصيلات سابقه كان
رد
الفلسطينيه يتك
ثف بشكل متتالي ومتزامن بعد انهاء مراسم
التشييع هذا ما شهدناه في
تغطيه مباشره لكل التطورات من القطاع اذا
تلك كانت اخر التطورات كما تابعنا من
الصحفي محمد عوض
تتابعون ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد
الفاصل
واشنطن تجدد تحفظها على عوده سوريا
للجامعه العربيه وتصف ذلك بالخطوه غير
المستحقه مؤكده رفضها لتطبيع العلاقات مع
دمشق
اهلا بكم من جديد قالت الاداره العسكريه
في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف ان انظمه
الدفاع الجوي تتصدى لهجمات روسيا على
المدينه بعد اطلاق انذارات جويه في عموم
البلاد تاتي الهجمات بعد ان اطلقت روسيا
اكبر هجماتها بطائرات المسيره حتى الان في
اطار حمله جويه بداتها قبل عشره ايام بعد
فتره هدوء منذ اوائل مارس
[موسيقى]
مع احتفالاتها بعيد النصر انشغلت روسيا
بوضع لمسات الاخيره استعدادا للاحتفال
بواحده من اهم مناسباتها السنويه رغم
الخطوات العسكريه التي اتخذتها سلطات فان
المخاوف بشان الامن الداخلي بعد سلسله
ضربات جويه اربكت الوضع وادت الى الغاء
احتفالات في بعض المدن فضلا عن حاله
التاهب الاوكراني والدولي تحسبا لاي
تطورات ميدانيه وفي المقابل على رئيس
الاوكراني
اوكرانيا ستتخلى عن احياء ذكرى الانتصار
على المانيا في الحرب العالميه الثانيه في
التاسع من مايو وفقا للتقليد السوفيتي
الروسي واضاف انه سيقدم الى البرلمان
مشروع قانون يعلن الثامن من مايو يوم
الذكرى والنصر على النازيه حسب تعبيره
لن نسمح بالاستيلاء على الانتصار المشتركي
لشعوب التحالف المناهض الهتلر ولن نسمح
باكاذيب كان النصر كان يمكن ان يتم دون
مشاركه اي دوله او شعب دمرنا الشر معا مثل
ما نواجه الان شرا مشابها معا
بانتظار الحرف في اوكرانيا اختارت الصين
موقفا لا يصفه اي طرف بالحيادي رفض الدعم
روسيا بالسلاحه والاصطفاف وراء العقوبات
الغربيه وقفوا الرمادي لم يمنع شركات
الصينيه من استغلال الفراغ الذي تركته
الشركات الغربيه في روسيا وهو ما قلل من
مفعول العقوبات الغربيه قبل ان تتحرك
واشنطن وتضغط املا في تغيير المعادله
الصينيه الروسيه
عقوبات لا تحصى وحصار اقتصادي لم يخطر على
بالي اكثر الروس تشاؤما
ووراء كل حزمه عقوبات اوروبيه تضحيه جديده
الا ان المنطقه الرماديه التي اختارتها
الصين جعلت من العقوبات مجرد خطه لا تمثل
الواقع
بمرور اشهر الحرب حل الواقع مكان التفاؤل
اذ لم تنفذ صواريخ روسيا بل بالعكس تخطط
صناعتها ازمه الرقائق واشباه الموصلات ولم
يبقى امام النيتو الا الحل الاخير
تجفيف المنبع ومعاقبه الشركات الصينيه
الثقه بين الاتحاد الاوروبي والصين ستنهار
اذا فرضت بروكسل عقوبات على شركات صينيه
بزعم انها تساعد روسيا اوروبا قد تدخل
حربا امريكيه بالوكاله وتضع على المحك
علاقتها باكبر شركائها الاقتصاديين تقول
لغه تهديد واضحه تزامنت مع سياسه اليد
الممدوده التي رفعها وزير الخارجيه الصيني
الذي يبدا جولته الاوروبيه من باريس و
برلين وهما اكثر الدول اعتدالا في
العلاقات مع بلاده
العقوبات لا تزال حبيسه المسوده الا ان
استهداف سبعا من شركات التكنولوجيا الابرز
قد يفتح الباب للمزيد من العقوبات
والعقوبات المضاده في الوقت الذي تستفيد
الصين من تداعيه الحرب بفاعليه
يبدو ان الخطوات الامريكيه كانت اسرع من
ماكرون الذي عاد من الصين وهو يتلو عبارات
الاستقلاليه الاوروبيه ما يفتح الباب امام
انقسام اوروبيين حول جدول دخول صراع مع
الصين خدمه للاستراتيجيه الامريكيه دليل
اخر واشنطن لم تنجح في فرض العقوبات على
الصين عبر مجموعه السبع وتجد صعوبه مماثله
في فرض حظر تجاري كامل على روسيا بعد ان
فشلت قبلها في اقناع فكين بالمفهوم الغربي
للحياد وهي التي منحت لشركاتها حريه
التعامل مع من تريد مقابل حصولها على
الكثير من النفط والغاز
المقومين باليوان
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه عبد
الفتاح البرهان ان الجيش السوداني اقترب
من انهاء وجود الدعم السريع في الخرطوم
عبر البرهان في تصريحات ادلى بها للاعلام
المصري عن شركره للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
على استضافتها للمفاوضات الهادفه لوقف
القتال في السودان كما اعرب البرهان عن
خشيه القوات المسلحه من انتقال الحرب الى
ولايات سودانيه اخرى مشيرا الى استحاله
الحديث عن اي موعد لوقف اطلاق النار حاليا
خاصه في ظل تمركز قوات الدعم السريع في
الاحياء السكنيه شدد البرهان في الوقت
ذاته على ان الحل السلمي هو الطريق الامثل
لحل الازمه الحاليه في السودان
ميدانيا تجددت الاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في مناطق عده
في الخرطوم حيث ارتفعت اعمده الدخان في
العاصمه في وقت يجتمع ممثلون عن الجيش
والدعم في جده لبحث وقف اطلاق النار وفتح
ممرات انسانيه وسبل انهاء الازمه وكان
مراسل العربيه فهذا باشتباكات جرت صباح
اليوم في ام درمان والخرطوم وسمع اصوات
مضادات في وقت حلقت فيه الطائرات في سماء
العاصمه السودانيه
رحب رئيس المؤتمر السوداني عمر الدقير
بالتزام وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان بالوقوف الى جانب السودان
حتى الوصول الى بر الامان واضافت في بيان
ان فرص نجاح المبادره التي تقودها الرياض
بمعيه واشنطن عاليه وهو ما سيسمح بتخفيف
حده الكارثه الانسانيه وتهيئه الارضيه
الاعلان وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
وحضر رئيس المؤتمر السوداني من اطاله امد
الحرب مما سيتيح الفرصه لاصحاب اجنده
خارجيه جر البلاد نحو الفوضى الشامله
وبخصوص مفاوضات جده جددت امله في ان يقدر
ممثله الطرفين معاناه الشعب السوداني من
اجل التوافق على ترتيبات تفضي الى معالجه
الاوضاع الانسانيه الكارثيه في البلاد
قال والي ولايه البحر الاحمر ان مدينه
بورسودان استقبلت عددا كبيرا من المواطنين
ومنسوبي المنظمات الدوليه واضاف ان 98
دوله اجنبيه اجلت رعاياها الى الخارج
الولايه الكبير جدا من الاخوان
لبلدانهم من مختلف جنسيات من
دبلوماسيين مواطنين منسوبين منظمات
العالميه
[موسيقى]
انتقدت الولايات المتحده قرار جامعه الدول
العربيه استئناف مشاركه وفود الحكومه
السوريه في اجتماعاتها معتبره ان الرئيس
بشار الاسد لا يستحق تطبيعا للعلاقات اثر
النزاع الثاني
تنتقد اعاده سوريا لجامعه الدول العربيه
مع نظام الاسد وان عقوباتنا على سوريا
ستظل ساريه المفعول هذا كان تصريح المتحدث
باسم البيت الابيض كارين بدورهم اعضاء في
الكونجرس من الحزبين حظ الولايات المتحده
على استخدام العقوبات لمنع التطبيع مع
الاسد
وجاء في بيان مشترك ان اعاده سوريا الى
مقعدها في الجامعه العربيه خطا استراتيجي
فادح
الكونجرس فرض قيودا على الولايات المتحده
تمنعها من تقديم اي مساعده لاعاده الاعمار
في سوريا قبل محاسبه المسؤولين على
الانتهاكات خلال الحرب
[موسيقى]
لا نعتقد ان سوريا تستحق اعادتها الى
جامعه الدول العربيه في الوقت الحاضر ولا
ندعم حلفائنا وشركائنا في القيام بذلك هذا
ما صرحه المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه
الذي قلل من اهميه الخلافات مع الدول
العربيه
وشدد على ان ل واشنطن اهداف مشتركه مع
العديد من شركائها العرب بشان سوريا
الخارجيه الامريكيه اكدت انها ستعمل على
وصول المساعدات الانسانيه الى السوريين
ودعم استقرار لمنع عوده ظهور تنظيم داعش
اختتمت المرافعات في قضيه تنظر فيها محكمه
مدنيه في نيويورك وتتهم فيها الكاتبه
الامريكيه الرئيس الامريكيه
في تسعينيات القرن الماضي والتشهير بها
وقالت محاميه
كارولان امام محكمه منهاتنا الفيدراليه ان
لا احد فوق القانون ولا حتى الرئيس السابق
مطالبه بادانه ترامب بالتحرش الى العمل
غارات اسرائيليه على غزه تقتل 12 شخصا
بينهم ثلاثه من القياديين العسكريين في
حركه الجهه
تزامنا مع احتفالات يوم النصر انظمه
الدفاع الجوي الاوكرانيه تتصدى لهجمات
الروسيه على العاصمه ومعظم مدن البلاد
ومع تصاعد وتيره الاشتباكات البرهان يحذر
من انتقال الصراع مع الدعم السريع الى
ولايه سودانيه اخرى
نهايه النشره الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات